dans le bourg de case-pilote la
discussion est sur toutes les lèvres
déjà soumis à des taux élevés la commune
voix pour l'année 2018 augmenter sa taxe
d'habitation alors même que le
gouvernement annonce une diminution de
30 % de la part de l'état si gavroche et
guy forget - lot d'armes à l'eau
minérale j'ai pas là on a déjà pas mal
de charges à payer et pour augmenter
sauf qu'en plus durer a pas de travail
safra disons manque 10 au niveau finance
cette façon c'est avec une augmentation
s'entraîne toujours une perte de pouvoir
d'achat ont cessé de l'état sud accord
mais si ça vient de la commune d'hubert
général on n'accepte pas et ce
contribuable ne croit pas si bien dire
car selon le maire de la commune en
proie à des difficultés financières
depuis plusieurs années cette bosse leur
a tout simplement été imposée nous avons
voté un budget le préfet a regardé notre
budget nous a soutenus sur le budget
mais la cour des comptes nous a imposé
une augmentation de cette taxe qui est
de l'ordre de 5%
cette augmentation qui a été décidé par
la cour des comptes découle d'une
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
depuis 2013 nous n'avons rien décidé
croyez moi que s'il n'y avait pas eu ça
on aurait certainement pas toucher à
cette taxe quatre autres communes ont
aussi augmenté leur taxe d'habitation
le robert bros rivière saint joseph ou
encore macouba mais ici il s'agit bien
de vote du causse et me
là on conscience le conseil municipal a
décidé d'augmenter de quelques points la
taxe d'habitation
tout simplement il ya une diminution des
recettes
deuxièmement on étend sur le plan
national un gel de la dotation globale
de fonctionnement entre guillemets et
nous avons donc pris la décision
d'augmenter de deux points
la taxe d'habitation plus de 6000
communes françaises ont voté cette
augmentation qui s'élève en moyenne à
0,5 point une taxe d'habitation qui
devrait disparaître progressivement
d'ici 2021